what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Kyle bass is the
founder and chief investment officer of
Heyman Capital in this conversation we
discussed the housing short trade that
made him famous what it was like to buy
millions of dollars of nickels what he
believes is happening in Hong Kong today
with the structural issues that he sees
in the global economy are and what
Kyle's thoughts are on Bitcoin and its
future I really enjoyed this
conversation and I hope you do as well
before we kick off this podcast first a
word from our sponsor block Phi as many
of you know crypto investors store their
digital assets on exchanges or in cold
storage for long term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth with the new block by
interest account users can now securely
store their Bitcoin or Ethernet block
buy and receive 6% annual interest paid
monthly in cryptocurrency 6% is an
absurdly high rate it's the best rate in
the industry I highly suggest you go
check out block Viacom / pump again
that's blocked by calm / pop to sign up
and start earning crypto today anthony
pomp leon o is a partner at Morgan Creek
digital all opinions expressed by pomp
or his guests on this podcast are solely
their opinions and do not reflect the
opinions of Morgan Creek digital or
Morgan Creek Capital Management you
should not treat any opinion expressed
by pomp as a specific inducement to make
a particular investment or follow a
particular strategy but only as an
expression of his opinion this podcast
is for informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I am here with
Kyle we were actually sitting in his
home in Dallas Texas so thank you so
much for taking time out your day to do
this absolutely um people want to know a
lot you've kind of done a bunch of stuff
in your life maybe let's just start if
you can give us kind of 30 seconds on
how you describe your background
I'll ask you then about a couple of
other trade you guys have made
previously and we can get into some of
the more recent stuff how I describe my
background I think I'm just
intellectually curious and unfortunately
like to be a contrarian were where where
it makes sense and I think that what we
do is affirm what I look to do is be a
global event driven investor and I know
that encompasses a lot of different
asset classes a lot of different
environments and ideas but that's
typically what we do
got it and so one of those big trades
obviously was the housing situation
chelsa seven tails and they maybe talk a
little bit about kind of what you guys
did there what led you to kind of become
interested yeah there was there was an
aha moment when you know back back then
if you remember China had ascended to
the WTO in 2001 and really in earnest
called 2003-2004 you saw our Rust Belt
the United States start to really
hemorrhage jobs so there were
significant job losses across you know
called the industrial belt of the US and
at that point in time that was still
market if you remember of three oh four
oh five that was when when you had you
know Greenspan had taken rates down to
1% he'd left them there probably too
long and we had our massive housing boom
in and we started raising rates in
really June of Oh four and you had
housing continued to do better because
instead of a housing downturn anote for
what you saw was Wall Street have built
this machine of securitization they just
decided to dip down lower and lower in
the credit spectrum so rates didn't
really affect the total number of homes
being sold and in the Rust Belt itself
you actually saw job losses and home
price declines and so we I was on a call
at one point in time in 2006 early oh-6
with an analyst our
a mortgage-backed securities analysts
Royal Bank of Scotland and I was trying
to isolate securitizations that had
larger concentrations in the Rust Belt
mm-hmm because we knew you were seeing
home fresh declines and job losses and
historically that that was was the that
was the tell-tale signal of a of a bad
securitized asset and I was running
through a model with him and I said so
what if home prices across the u.s. just
go flat for a year because he had sent
me a model of up six up seven of eight
and I said but what about zero I mean
since yeah that doesn't happen so we
don't even have it in our models and I
said what if just hypothetically maybe
there was just a zero for again of a
price to climb he said well in a zero
you know these securitizations would
lose three to six percent of their
assets and I said but that would wipe
out the triple piece he says yeah but
you know that's not going to happen and
that was that moment where you thought
if you could find a decent concentration
of a securitization of the Rust Belt but
also we thought housing was gonna
flatten out and God forbid it go down
even who's gonna wipe out a lot of these
securitization but that that's what
that's what now that's that was the aha
moment got it was just being curious
into in that situation you guys have
capital that you can go and deploy in a
situation you have to go convince
investors
look I launched my fund and really
february of those six our goal with
macro fund February of of six with
thirty three million dollars hmm and a
chunk of that was my savings whatever I
was one of the biggest investors and so
when we came up one side ironed out that
idea which caught that was calling June
May June of oh six we went we took that
idea to investors and launched a
subprime only vehicle in September of
2016
got it Oh chefs and six I'm sorry sorry
22 2006 cut it okay and then and so as
you go through that were there like the
psychology of you put an idea together
right
you go and you pitch investors you get
some that are interested and then you
kind of sit and wait because things
really didn't get nasty until 2007 2008
or was interesting about that as things
were getting nasty in 2006 guys so you
pretty much saw right away hey we're
most likely right 23rd day of every
month the performance report of all of
the loans within these securitizations
is released mm-hmm it's released in tax
it's released to these data services and
you get to you get to see how they're
performing and their performance was
constantly deteriorating mmm and in fact
we launched our phone in September of
2006 unlike I can't remember the day
September 16th or 17th people said why
don't you just wait till October first
us I can't wait for another performance
report because what if the market falls
apart it's doing so poorly right now
early payment defaults were spiking that
means people that don't even pay their
first mortgage payment wow those were
spiking and call it third quarter of
2006 EPDs were spiking performance was
deteriorating they were all still rated
triple-a and you know for all intents
and purposes and we would have meetings
and say why aren't they falling apart
right now so if you remember February of
2007 was the first time that there was a
break in the bottom end of that of the
structure of these securitizations and
then from February to June of o7 they
actually rally back up thank God because
we were trying to get five billion
dollars invested and I needed every
sucker I can find and unfortunately we
didn't get the whole five billion
investment yeah it kind of dried up it's
funny because one constant across a lot
of investors who have these more macro
you know approaches to the world they
come up with a single idea they have a
lot of conviction in it you hear the
same thing over and over again I knew it
was gonna happen but I didn't want it to
happen immediately because I wanted to
get more money into the trade right and
so hearing that is pretty interesting
another tray that you're well known for
I think at this point is the Nichols um
so you took a bunch of money and you
bought Nichols explain a little bit
about what the logic there was actually
wasn't quote
and it had nothing new with investor
capital it was you know in in seeing
what world governments did including our
own in response to the 2008 7:8 crisis
we all know what happened right central
bank balance sheets went out of control
and so whether whether it was the US or
Europe or Japan or China you name it
they they grew their central bank
balance sheets like like weeds and I was
trying to explain that to my kids and
talking to my kids I was explained to
them that this is the new path this is
what's going to happen there is no going
there is no going back there is no
return to a gold standard or return to
some fixed asset standard it's not going
to happen can't happen
mmm because then growth gets cut off and
you have all kinds of bankruptcies and
we know that that just can't happen so
in talking to the kids about it I said
so rates are at zero there's no
opportunity cost you're not learning
anything in your bank account so why
wouldn't you go home the actual metals
right then basically copper and nickel
and nickels and at the time copper and
nickel together there was worth about
six cents and nickels were worth five
cents so where in the world is there a
free perpetual option on metal mm-hmm
well in the marketplace you actually
have to pay a pretty significant price
to buy a two-year copper option or a
nickle option and in taking down nickels
you got it for free mm-hmm so I was just
teaching my kids that I'd rather own a
bunch of nickels than have my money
sitting in the bank while the Federal
Reserve prints it away
yep and again that was just a teaching
moment had nothing to do with call it
true capitalism or return on investment
yeah it's pretty cool that you're having
those conversations so early in their
lives right where they can tell you
story I've never told before okay he's
saying this with a grin on his face this
one's gonna be good this is a fun one
you know in 2000 and in 2008 early only
before Bear Stearns you know went down I
was I was driving in my car
my son wasn't in the car and at that
time he was he was eight years old all
right so yeah he's almost 20 yeah so
roughly eight years old and I had just
taught him the year in a year year
before that you know he he my son never
spent his earnings whatever he did
chores around the house or did a job for
a neighbor or something he would always
see his money always take it and even
save it in cash
in his box and I explained to him this
concept of interest and that if you put
it with a bank the government ensures it
so you're not going to lose it and
you're an interest and so the the
closest bank to our house at the time
was a window and if you remember when
whose entire balance sheet was was
option arms mm-hmm okay so I was talking
with a good friend of mine in New York
and I was on the phone and we were
talking about which banks were safe and
which banks were unsafe if you remember
we were thinking about where where to
put your money yep when we were all
wondering which bank was actually going
to be solvent with their levered balance
sheets and he says you know what about
whammy on us and we'll look when is all
option arms and said they are done I
don't care that Bob steals our new CEO
when mu is finished I said they're going
to be bankrupt and the government
probably have to take them over and I go
through all this with my good friend
who's another asset manager and I hung
up and my son in the back seat says so
so dad the way mu you were just talking
about uses is that the one where my
money yes Sam but you have nothing to
worry about
nothing to worry about he says dad I
want my money out so so we went I took
him to the bank we went in we filled out
the the deposit you know or they started
with the withdrawal request for his
entire credit balance of whatever it was
eight hundred and fifty dollars at the
times a lotta money and this very nice
lady was at the counter and she said oh
oh you were so cute
you know what are you gonna go spend
this on are you gonna buy you know a
Nintendo or Sony Playstation won't even
spend it on he says no ma'am your bank's
going out of business and I need my
money look where it goes out of business
he said my dad says that you have you're
gonna be
and an 8 year old on her face and my son
and I merge its so funny we're just
driving yesterday by this Bank who's no
longer no longer a limo and we were both
reminiscing about that time when he went
in and and convinced the teller that she
was in real trouble
they year-old knew better than the
people who work there for sure and I
appreciate that Hong Kong you've you've
been quite vocal about a lot of the
structural problems going on there maybe
describe a little bit about the pegging
and kind of the the challenges that you
saw and it's now probably 2 3 years ago
at this point when you really started to
pay attention and then what's transpired
in your mind in terms of you know really
proving that you guys were spot-on with
with the analysis I think we understand
this idea of two you know two countries
and one system or really how they say
one country in two systems in just over
those they don't know cos talking about
China and Hong Kong they're technically
they're a special administrative region
of China yep ie you know Great Britain
ruled Hong Kong for a long time right
things they basically took took over
Hong Kong in the opium wars and then
took over the rest of the the outer area
of Hong Kong Kowloon and the rest you
know in the second that would be war and
I think that they basically signed a
99-year lease and then Deng Xiaoping
went to Thatcher and said we want it
back and that was that was in really
that the late 70s and early 80s these
conversations started to be had and if
you remember as those conversations were
had being had after Hong Kong was ruled
by Britain for so long and had a rule of
law and had
a judiciary an economic system and the
legislative system that again had order
and had law a lot of money was invested
there man if you look back to 1980
call it 80 cults from 79-83 so the
currencies been pegged since since 83 to
the dollar but from 79-83 the Hong Kong
dollar lost 50% of its value versus both
the British Pound and the US dollar
because everyone was worried that if
China were to get pom come back that
there would be the heavy hand of China's
Communist Party and economic policies
that are let's say substandard and and
no autonomy and they're fewer no one
will leave their money there so the
first currency panic that really
happened there was as a result of
China's potential takeover
fast-forward to a peg in 83 to the
dollar because it was literally out of
control hmm
and in 84 was when Thatcher signed the
deal with Dinka pang of China and they
they basically signed what they called
the the the British are the the British
you know 1984 started joint declaration
of 1984 which stipulated that they are
going to the Brits were going to hand
back Hong Kong to the Chinese in 97 mmm
and that was going to be a fifty year to
go mighty China was going to abide by
this agreement the agreement is to
remain autonomous ie
one country two systems one country
being China China's gonna own them both
but it's going to allow it to maintain
its autonomy in both in the economy the
judiciary and the legislature yep and so
that agreement was signed by both
parties
there is no adjudicative let's say
review of that deal meaning if one side
breaks it there is no de-escalation
there's no negotiation either this is an
agreement or it's not and that's kind of
where we find ourselves today but
there's an interesting fun fact also as
as we headed into the handoff of Hong
Kong back to Chinese in 97 what happened
the Asian financial crisis right and so
the handoff was July 1st 1997 and when
did the Thai Baht break its peg things
like they after a very next day
that's not coincidental the money
started running out of Southeast Asia
primarily Hong Kong because it was it's
a financial center due to the British
law and the money started running and so
they had an existential crisis many
currencies broke pegs Hong Kong back
then held the pay but as a result they
suffered a massive depression real
estate drops seventy five percent in
value imagine
real estate dropping seventy five
percent what that would do to a banking
system and an economy now how do we get
from like that mass panic and you know
all the concern money running etc to
more stability over the last you know
call it almost twenty years right took
twenty years or so so that China
basically decided to stand behind its
commitment in the nineteen eighty-four
sino-british joint declaration and also
the US Hong Kong Policy Act of 92 where
we decided to treat Hong Kong as its own
separate sovereign territory as long as
China lived up to its end of the agreed
on it and didn't infringe on the
autonomy of Hong Kong in any of those
three areas we re review we re under
that we as a country on the right that
agreement every year the State
Department writes a letter to the
President and says either we believe
Hong Kong sufficiently autonomous or not
the Brits actually really write it twice
here so you can go to Parliament and
read what the British essentially State
Department rights to their prominent and
what you've seen in the so think about
this the last ten years of Hong Kong's
life has been the best ten years that
they'll ever see reason being they're
pegged to the US economy they're paid to
our central bank we took rates to zero
in 2008 and their largest trading
partner China went to the gas pedal they
had the golden years of Hong Kong they
had free money and they had a market
that a real estate market that
berserk one six seven hundred percent
ten years imagine that yep
now they're the most expensive real
estate market in the world they have the
most leverage of any developed economy
in the world they're their private
sector credit to GDPs three hundred
percent the US and Japan is a little
less than 150 mmm okay you know however
Japan is and however the u.s. is to
slowly double yeah double and double at
a very low base so when their rates
start moving up it hamstrings our entire
economy again they've had a real estate
market go to the moon and then they also
have the one of those levered banking
systems in the world they're nine
hundred percent of GDP in their banking
system assets again so when losses just
start to trickle through the bank equity
disappear cube right in the US financial
crisis we all in including off-balance
sheet financing we're about 1.75 X
they're going X want to put things into
perspective
today we're one x right we are and if
you include Fannie and Freddie
you know we're call it 1.5 okay and then
describe so this idea of pegging the
Hong Kong dollar to the US dollar and
what you originally saw as to why the
peg can't possibly work for two separate
economies yeah I just don't imagine a
rigid financial relationship rigid
meaning there's a peg at a level for 36
years okay for 10 20 years you think
about back in 83 as the world went as
the u.s. went in the world that idea of
we grew the rest of the world grew with
us and if we decline the rest of the
world had a small recession with us we
were leave we were the economic engine
of the world today one could argue that
China is since the financial crisis
pulled the world out of the world
financial crisis ie
their economic growth kind of pulled the
world mm-hmm and they are still they
still run about a 13 trillion dollar
economy and we we have about a 20
trillion dollar economy so we're still
almost twice as big as they are but
they've grown a lot and so I think
that what you see happening now is Hong
Kong is now completely dependent upon
China for their GDP its service growth
so it's real estate services financial
services legal accounting that is Hong
Kong's and travel that's Hong Kong's
economy used to be they were an exporter
reacts border of goods for southern
China now they're a service-based
economy facing China
so if our rates go down while China's
economy blows up in a good way
then Hong Kong has a great ten years
you've already start to move up and
trying to continues to slow down that is
the death knell for Hong Kong and now
that's what we saw the other most
interesting part of that is you could
sell forward Hong Kong dollars and they
pay you while you had a soul ie it was a
very pot was a positive clear
intersection yeah so if you were
Japanese over European and you have
negative rates mm-hmm wouldn't it be
more fun and have a positive carry in
position and the most lever to develop
the economy in the world mm-hmm and if
you're in Hong Kong and you have you
have free convertibility between US
Dollars and Hong Kong dollars you'd
actually have to be a fool to hold the
Hong Kong dollar mm-hmm right because of
all of these reasons I give you you
don't even have to agree with me yep you
actually just earned more money holding
dollars for sure why not on the dollar
and so as you guys see this coming
together right you went out and
literally said hey we believe that this
is gonna be a problem here's why and
what we've seen transpire over the last
two to three years I think just now
people in the Western world who aren't
specifically focused on Hong Kong or
starting to see it creep into mainstream
media come I would say Creek it's on the
front page of every paper for the last
few weeks selects two weeks so test now
at the beginning is necessary to our
idea yes so at the beginning of the year
I think if you asked kind of a normal
American they would have no clue that
there was any you know trouble on the
horizon and Hong Kong probably last four
to six weeks now you know it's really
hey every single day they see the videos
you know of the the white gang
you know beating people they see the
photos of people with kind of blood
running down their faces and it's I
think most Americans would say
something's going on I haven't really
been paying attention but there's kind
of unrest right from somebody who's been
paying attention for years now kind of
describe what's transpired from the last
six months and why it's all coming to a
head now so there's a much longer
situation going on with the relationship
between China and Hong Kong and what
China is trying to do to further control
Hong Kong's economy Hong Kong is the
epicenter of where China raises dollars
in the world it's important to
understand China how many times have you
talked about China's economy and you say
well I think they're gonna have a
recession and I think they're going to
be better and someone says you have it
there China they can do whatever they
wanted so in China the Chinese
government controls everything they
control the printing press they control
price levels they control the police and
they control the narrative now the
control of people with Orwellian social
credit score mm-hmm they literally
control everything so you and I can sit
here and say but they can do whatever
they want they can recap their banks in
army they can print more army they can
again do whatever they want I actually
agree with that hmm
but and if they did close system and
they didn't have to trade with the rest
of the world if they were not resource
rich hmm then we probably wouldn't be
doing anything mm-hmm here but what's
important is China has to interface with
the rest of the world and the rest of
the world won't take their shitty
currency huh I can say that on you could
say whatever you want no one's gonna
take monopoly money right and so it's
important to realize that China's FX
reserve balance is their working capital
it is what they they're desperately
short energy the largest importer of
crude oil in the world now they're
desperately short food they're
desperately short raw materials right
they are resource poor and so you see
China using belton Road around the world
to basically lend themselves into
acquiring big assets whether it's port
assets or mines or roads or airports or
governments they're lending their way
into resource rich areas speak for the
long run and so
for them to buy any resources they have
to spend dollars euros you know pounds
mostly dollars so they must maintain
this dollar balance so it's important to
realize that China is running a massive
fiscal deficit 10% of GDP or more just
think about that when the u.s. breaks 3%
of GDP Congress goes berserk China's
running a 10% of GDP fiscal deficit and
when you include their local government
financing and they're running a current
account that we think will go negative
from now on it has has never been
negative before it went negative just
recently and we think it's going to stay
negative if we don't have enough time to
get into that but their dollar balances
are going to start deteriorating yep so
how do they maintain a positive dollar
balance to keep growing their economy
well they get people like MSCI to make
the China waiting in the index go from
5% to 20% in just a couple of years
which is happening right now
mm-hm right they get someone in the
Bloomberg Ag & x AG bond and exhale
demon brothers bond index to add them to
that index and money flows into them
that way oh and then they open up their
capital markets for US investors to buy
more of their banks right after they
wreck their banks they say the spider
says to the fly away you can own more of
our banks then right but in the end they
need dollars of serious dollar flow so
Hong Kong is the epicenter where they
raise those dollars
Alibaba says we want to raise 20 billion
in a spot secondary in Hong Kong well of
course they do because money's fungible
Alibaba is run by the Chinese government
and they're just gonna sell them any
shares that they can to bring dollars
into China Inc so Hong Kong is
functionally very important to them from
a financial perspective and chomp uncle
chansik on imme has enabled them to be
more aggressive on the on the
geopolitical front right they take the
money they get in and they build
aircraft carriers and they build missile
systems and they build hypersonic this
and that that they steal from us but
they they need dollars to build these
things yep and so Hong Kong's really
important what China's did this February
they got Carrie Lam the CEO of Hong Kong
to introduce a bill kind of quietly
that stipulates that if China determines
anyone's are criminal in Hong Kong and
that's China's sole determination that
they can extradite them and and
basically hold them accountable in China
so they can take them out of Hong Kong
bring them to China and additionally
maybe if they say Anthony you came to
Beijing oh and there's no statute of
limitations so you came to Beijing 20
years ago you stepped foot there and
they said you know you raped a girl
mm-hmm and if the allegation carries if
the conviction would carry more than a
seven year penalty then you're
extradited you have no questions asked
in the Hong Kong Court and as you know
the Chinese use political persuasion and
their legal system is a kangaroo court
and so they're 85,000 Americans that
live in Hong Kong anyone that's
literally the lands in Hong Kong on a
stopover if you're gonna land in
Singapore or Hong Kong in the past you
probably say I don't care which one it
is but now you're gonna say I'm never
gonna win an encore if you're trying to
congrat me I'm gonna go to Singapore yep
and so it's important to realise that
the citizens of Hong Kong realized that
there's no statute of limitations and
now they're subject to the call of the
whims of the Chinese Communist Party it
basically completely violates the
British Chinese agreement yes and the US
Attorney the u.s. Chinese agreement the
u.s. Hong Kong policy after 92 and so ie
Hong Kong must remain sufficiently
autonomous and what you're seeing today
what you're seeing the sector addition
bill is their autonomy is gone mmm it's
just a question of time for when China
sends in the PLA their army through
Shenzhen into Hong Kong and then it's
over
mmm so any any hope that the Hong Kong
people have had for a true democracy
maintain a rule of law and be be the
center that they've always hoped it was
going to be that's been extinguished so
I want such one more thing before we get
to more on global macro and Bitcoin
stuff but I saw you tweeting about
recently there's these videos of
basically gangs of men running into
train stations all dressed in white
and what I've gathered is basically the
police are not participating in
protecting the citizens there's these
gangs that are beating up you know it's
the teachers it's the journalists it's
the protesters it's all stuff and what
it looks like is those gangs will allow
somebody most likely the Chinese
government to step in and say we must
protect the people and therefore they
will then send in the army the police
whoever to kind of take control what's
interesting is if you if you follow this
on a daily basis and you know people
throughout Hong Kong both in their
government and in that in just the
citizenship what you see is the initial
protests whether it was the lawyers the
3,000 or so lawyers that protested the
extradition bill silently walking from a
walking to Parliament or the 1 million
protesters or the 2 million that showed
up on the on the biggest day 2 million
people only seven and a half million
people in Hong Kong imagine if a quarter
of the US population ever protest in
anything right that would be crazy
70 million people or more that would be
on just on an order of magnitude you
can't understand you can't where do you
put them all just think two million
people but the two million person
protests if you saw the pictures in the
videos that people took it was perfectly
I was it was perfectly clean it was
perfectly nonviolent and then post those
marches Carrie Lam said you know despite
the fact that two of seven and a half
million stood outside in 97 degree
weather for an entire day to protest
this bill I'm gonna go ahead and put it
through and then people went a little
bit more crazy but you've just recently
seen these triads these gang members
come in in the white shirts with poles
pose sorry bamboo poles iron poles and
even machetes and they beat the living
hell out of some of the protesters and I
mean it looked like the Rodney King
beating in the United States I haven't
seen anything like that on video in a
long time and that Hong Kong riot police
are in the periphery turn around and
walk the other way while their own
citizens get beaten almost to death and
so you
the police are complicit and in fact
there are many photos of the police with
the riders beforehand
almost like game planning and you gotta
know if you've seen these but I have not
no soso collaborator so the police are
in on it and the police are run by the
government and the government is really
run by China and the probationers and I
think it's important to realize that you
know in Xinjiang where the Chinese have
at least a million and US intelligence
believes it's three million political
prisoners based upon their religious
preference it's starting to sound like a
real problem like a Hitler type problem
because they're they're the the UK just
determined they were live organ
harvesting from these people and they're
just political prisoners because of
their religious preference so those
things don't make it into the mainstream
media because you can't take pictures
the Chinese will never let that happen
she's existential nightmares Hong Kong
because it was technically free and
democratic before and everyone has smart
phones and cameras in the internet so
all of these pictures circulate on the
internet and so everything he's doing to
incite violence so we believe that the
Chinese government and the Chinese army
have brought in the Triads and the gangs
to beat the people to create violence so
that China can come in and rescue Hong
Kong from these violent times with their
own army and then again that's enough
sow any autonomies yeah that is what's
going to happen next moment
watch what happens that's what will
happen next um in one sentence what is
the way that you guys plan to from asset
management perspective like how do you
play all that happening yeah I just
think the the common denominator is this
peg between the Hong Kong currency and
the US currency and we think that that
that Hong Kong needs a peg but we think
that that peg will be to the Chinese
currency or a basket of Southeast Asian
currencies where their economies move in
tandem mm-hmm and not with the United
States got it let's just switch gears
real quick two more the global economy
right in terms of I think there's a lot
of people who say there's warning signs
whether it's the inverted yield curves
or other
kind of alarms going off that there's
likely to be an economic downturn at
some point you know in the short term
whether that's six months 12 months 36
months whatever how do you think about
the central bank reaction to that and
then as part of that talk me through
your framework for evaluating something
like gold or Bitcoin that's a pretty big
open-ended question there Anthony look
we think that we think that you're going
to see a slowdown in Southeast days you
are already seeing it China's growing at
the slowest rate that's grown at in the
last 35 years and that's what they're
reported so we all know that when the
books are in the oven yeah I see
something even better than that is real
so we think they're growing GDP two or
three percent in fact last year could
have been flat and so if if Southeast
Asia is going to have a zero GDP or
small recession then the rest of the
world will grow a little less so again I
don't expect a 2008 style I don't know
where to put my money crisis I think
you're going to see a shallow recession
in the developed world a deeper
recession and then in the Asian world
from Southeast Asian world and what does
that mean right that means that the
central banks were just print more mmm
right you're seeing today we're
expecting at the end of this month we're
here in July of 2019 you know part of
the market believes we're gonna have 50
bit cut the other you know the other
cadre believes we'll have a quarter
point cut at three point seven percent
unemployment we're still it we're still
at emergency levels of rates and we're
talking about cutting rates again mm-hmm
so and is it there QE and printing of
money is really just because the central
makes al have two tools of cutting rates
or printing money or is it something
else that you think they're kind of tied
to I think I think that in the event
that you have a small recession and if
you're near the zero lower bound you
have very few to very few who it's just
dealing a betting initiative
Japan okay people say well how long can
this go on you know the the Tea Partiers
and by the way I'm technically a tea
partier from the perspective of looking
at financial economics but people say
how long can it go on you can say well
if this is the tactic then it can go on
almost forever in a nominal world the
Bank of Japan owns seventy seven percent
of every ETF in Japan
Wow they are a top ten holder in four of
the largest companies of Japan mm-hmm
just think about that they've been
buying stocks for a very long time and
they're gonna keep buying stocks they
own over a hundred percent of the bonds
of Japan mmm of Japan Inc they've
monetized a hundred percent of GDP of
their deficit and I asked one of Japan's
top central bankers at a breakfast that
was private and I said you know you say
you don't monetize your debt and yet you
own over a hundred and ten percent of
GDP of your death at the central bank so
what do you call that and he looked at
me nice it's you know Kyle saw we're all
me monetizing our debt when the market
tells us for monetizing our debt but
that that is how they think about it and
so that is it a path so what I'm
convinced of is the path we think the
path is easy simple okay you know the
cup h20 maybe some will even go you know
Newark mm-hmm
I don't I think Newark decimates the
banks and as you see Europe's all there
zombie banks has you know Deutsche Bank
just found a magical 80 billion euro
hole all of these banks have big holes
the US recap its banks your ups banks
are zombie banks and you know China's
banks are now levered more than any bank
has ever been lever in world history and
in nominal call it RMB but not in terms
of capital but all these banks there's
really no let each other go other than
two different yeah and then I know that
you guys have looked at Bitcoin
specifically over over something
at a time just what's the framework they
used to look at it and then kind of what
are some of the things that have kept
you guys from front from doing anything
there yeah yeah I think we spent a lot
of time before he had talking about this
so I'm leading him bottom line is as the
digital asset class began its growth so
back when Bitcoin very specifically was
$2,300 is when we were looking at
looking at this saying this is going to
be an asset class and I use Bitcoin in
kind of a collective term give this
crypto Bitcoin not speaking of the ico
securities that are crazy you know it's
just talking about pure crypto assets I
think I think that we tried to get
comfortable with the fact we are a
fiduciary we are regulated we are
governed by the regulatory bodies that
oversee fiduciary capital management and
we couldn't find what we deemed to be a
qualified custodian a qualified
custodian needs it needs to be called
stipulated by the Exchange Commission
and fed and all these people need to
approve as you probably know who was
holding the public key holding the
private key we as an asset manager can't
ever take possession of our assets for
instance when we own it if and when you
own gold you can take delivery of gold
into a bonafide Comex warehouse that is
a qualified custodian you can actually
take physical possession you just can't
put your hands on it it becomes illegal
for you as a fiduciary put your hands on
it and so that was the problem that we
ran into in hiring as many different
legal teams as we could hire and in this
evolution of asset prices our sorry
evolution of this asset class made it
difficult for us and so we began it at
$2,300 a Bitcoin in our that and we
stopped at about 4,000 a bit point on
its way to whatever it went to 20,000
and god only knows where it is today but
then then the the argument becomes as
you are not discussable earlier more
philosophical from the perspective of
putting yourself into central bankers
seat and or let's say more importantly
someone that's running the government of
the Treasury or the presidency of of any
sovereign nation when you think about
what your sovereign identity is and what
you can control and can't control this
is that ideological difference between
called a libertarian and a and a
sovereign government and I think you
probably know from reading anything I've
written that I fall more into the
libertarian camp and I'm a fiscal
conservative however when I think about
the rules-based system in the system
that's been developed the way it's been
developed I mentioned to you earlier
today I think that this asset class can
grow to a number I don't know what that
number is and today I actually don't
know what the whole asset class is worth
you probably 350 350 350 billion you
know could it go to a trillion probably
but I'll bet when it gets to a trillion
it becomes a much larger problem and it
require it will require almost
affirmative determinations by
governments that is either ok or not ok
with them and you could say well it's
too bad if it's not ok I'm gonna own it
and I it's decentralized and not condone
any my Japanese account I can own it in
this account and then this account well
the US government for instance has a
number of different things that they
require you to file with your tax return
every year that if you don't declare it
it's a felony mmm and last thing you
want to do is go to jail and so I
believe that there are structural things
that are going to happen when it becomes
more functioning relevant and more
widely about that but I do believe it's
going to be more relevant and more
adopted yeah I don't know where that
really puts me other than in a
philosophical vine well I think just
talking to you today it's um you
understand the philosophical arguments
behind it you have a pretty good
understanding of the technical how it
works why it has value in certain cases
all that I'm a huge proponent of the Box
chain I guess
I understand we have on Sept of the
immediacy and the and a perfect archive
let's say the perfect historical archive
of the the blockchain I buy that pub -
yeah I think your argument is a rational
one in the sense of if it actually works
you run into an obstacle now the
question is is that a roadblock we're
literally you can't get through it
because the government just clamps down
on it or is it more of a speed bump
right and it's kind of hey that you know
they got to do some work and then they
come out and say okay it's fine in you
know this sandbox or within these rules
but I think that even you know last
couple of weeks we've seen the Senate
that Congress you know literally the
chairman Federal Reserve the Treasury
secretary the president they've all
discussed Bitcoin cryptocurrency
Facebook's Libra etc they're not asleep
at the wheel right it's not like they're
not paying attention it's just a
question of you know how kind of
included they want to be or how active
do they want to be versus you know kind
of letting it just grow on its own
before they step in I think as you
mentioned earlier I think Facebook is
this has become the devil to both sides
of the aisle mm-hmm and the one thing
that Facebook doesn't have on you they
have your pictures they have your
identity they have any of your all your
friends are they know what you care
about they know a lot about you they
don't have your personal financial data
hmm and your social security number
guess what libras gonna get all of that
hmm and so whether they say it's
altruistic or whether they say it is the
business proposition for Facebook to
have that much data that much power I
think that's why you're seeing this
pushback and again this gets to my point
of can a cryptocurrency ever gain that
much power in its own right as a as a
challenger to a hegemonic system and I
believe its own success will be its own
problem and so you're just starting to
see some of that do I think this is the
top I wouldn't possibly call the top in
here yeah do I think it has more room to
run probably yeah
yes but do I think that that's gonna be
a speed bump or a roadblock
if I were betting
I bet it's more of a boat blocker and
speedboat but there'll be some along the
way that are speed bumps
it'll just what I'm tell you the
obstacles will get larger and larger the
more successful yeah
and I think also which jurisdiction
you're talking about is a whole other
thing right there's some there's some
jurisdictions that will say bring it all
yeah they're great places for it you
mentioned Argentina these trouble
third-world countries look Iran
Venezuela all of these absolute horrible
and communist socialist dictatorships
that have ended so greatly I mean this
is what everybody wants right everyone
wants there to be a perfect socialistic
communist government where everyone has
the same amount of money and
everything's gonna work great in
everyone else college and okay we all
know that's never going to work
go talk to the people that have tried it
mmm but those places sorry there's a
little political jump there but I think
those places show you that there is a
need to be able to save yourself from
hyperinflation from your government
getting it wrong right absolutely and I
think that is what's fueling a number of
the players today to think I need 1% of
my assets there are 50 bits or I need
four or five percent I mean some number
that's not going to break me if I'm
wrong it's some number that if the
government gets out of control with its
spending and its policies then I have
some store value right I mean this is
the whole argument and I buy that yep I
just if I put my Treasury secretary hat
on it's a problem yeah it's you're one
of the few people I've talked to that
understand the asset the benefit the
risk right and yet still can rationally
think about the outside forces then
don't care about you know kind of the
fundamentals if you go to some degree
yeah right and and those two things are
separate right and and frankly the
stronger the fundamentals the more your
concerns about so the other stuff
becomes real so listen I really
appreciate you taking all the time to do
this has been a lot of fun I promised
him that we would we would end on time
so he can go do some family stuff we
could talk for hours so thank you so
much a lot dude again thank you all
right guys thanks so much for listening
to that podcast before I let you go
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely to
posit your Bitcoin or ether at block 5
and receive 6% annual interest paid
monthly in cryptocurrency this rate
actually compounds so you receive a 6.2
percent a py which is very attractive
given the alternatives so you can
actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm / pump again
block 5 comm / pump to sign up and start
earning interest on your crypto today
hey everyone
pop here if you liked this episode of
off the chain and want to help us take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
home page scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain